I serve here tonight to hand over the
best documentary award yourself you've
made a very good documentary how many I
think you know a thing or two about it
how do you feel to be presenting tonight
pretty good yeah it was kind of a
last-minute thing but a really pleased
because I'm really good films were
nominated by my huge fan of the
imposters I'm very pleased for the
filmmakers for it winning yeah in terms
of center of course it was so widely
well received by audiences and critics
are like what do you think the secrets
making a good documentary to begin we've
gotta have a good character really good
current tone and have a good story to
tell and then if you can tell it in an
interesting way then it's another
element but the main thing is you've got
to start with the story
and a person that you want to follow and
in our case Center we had an incredibly
charismatic character and the same way
with the imposter you've got someone
that you just don't really understand
whether or not you trust this guy I
think that's really interesting what do
you think it was Merson Center that made
him so appealing as a person outside
even at the school it's really what he
stood for
you know he's his Amanda stuff stood for
his ideals no matter what refused to
kind of fold he was a genius at driving
but it's the manner outside of the car
that I think seeing that and seeing him
speak and seeing him how passionately he
felt about certain things I think that's
what people the audience saw watching
the movie that they didn't know about
they may have known about the driver but
it was a man that really made the film
exploded what's next for you Asif I've
got a couple of drummers that I'm
working on I'm hoping to get started on
am may be shooting any in the next year
I know there's also another documentary
I'm about to begin on so it's quite
hopefully one be busy this year we're
looking at sport again or something
completely different not sporting doc
I've talked about a couple but this
one's probably going to be an artist of
some kind of artist maybe a musical one
I'm just waiting for it to kind of sort
itself out so I can't say too much why
are they still with us maybe not what we
leave it that we look forward to finding
out lots more as soon as that's very and
the doramas as well the ending and the
dramas as well what can we look forward
in terms of like
well I kind of a nice epic there's an
epic that I'm looking to do which is
shooting in various countries and so
that's the one that's taking the world
to put together but hopefully I'll be
doing that so we're looking at Europe
there or a bit further afield it further
afield actually yes
lots more to look forward to from you
yeah yeah hopefully I'll be busy
shooting and editing next year and in a
year after it's great to be back here
you